it's you what did she tell him when she
got caught hey the first thing they said
is where's Matt Cox right I have no clue
he left me like a year ago and so
they're like damn she didn't know where
I am
yeah so at this point I'm uh you know
borrowing money at this point what's
happened is Amanda and I are one day
sitting in the dentist's office and she
picks up a a Bloomberg Businessweek and
keep in mind the st. Petersburg Times
which is now the Tampa Bay Times guy
there's a guy like Testament Jeff test
okay yeah they did
30 roughly 35 articles on me Tampa
Tribune did articles the was the Chicago
Tribune did them they did a whole series
called the fugitive the Atlanta
journal-constitution the I mean it just
it just goes you know so it's it's
everywhere at this point Dateline is
putting together a see a segment I was
in Fortune magazine did a whole segment
on Becky and her take of the whole
womanizer manipulator you know that
whole thing the the forcing boob jobs
forcing her to leave her son you know
just are you serious
so you know a bad guy you know so anyway
it's a so I'm with Amanda and we adjourn
we were going through the Mediterranean
we were all it took a cruise so it
sounds rough doesn't it sounds like a
lot of rough life I remember looking
over at Amanda might at this point she's
like 25 I'm like 30 she knows what
you're doing all your whole deal
she knows yeah and I look over at her
she's 25 bathing suit we're on a on a
European cruise ship going through the
Mediterranean you're living the good and
I'm like it wasn't by the way it wasn't
worth the prison there but I remember
thinking this is one of those moments
yeah this is amazing people are calling
me you know mr. Carter yeah I'm walking
through Passport you know how the Roses
yeah I'm walking well I'm walking
through passport control
boom hi mr. Carter you give
a passport I mean it's it's like James
Bond you feel like James Bond
when you walk into me when you walk into
Bank of America and you give them a
bunch of false documents and they're
calling you mr. black
yeah and they give you a check for
250,000 and then thank you for ripping
them off yeah you walk out like this is
this is better than the money yeah
forget some utter thrill right living in
a movie yeah it's ridiculous it really
is and you know right up until that
sentencing yeah so anyway what happens
is Amanda and I start seeing a man who
lives with me yeah we start seeing a
girl I dated this girl like one time and
Amanda you know you're you're you're
with a girl and you know eventually they
start saying you ever been interested
with another being with two women and
I'm like of course like you know oh yeah
I'm like no I would never do that I you
know have you ever done that I'm like
yes once it's bumpy and awkward it's
just it's just it's not my thing and and
she's like really I'm like yeah she's
like you would you be interested like
absolutely of course you know I was like
actually I said no no baby but I'll do
it for you out of love for you yeah I'm
not interested in here but I'll do it
for you so anyway we start seeing this
girl mmm she comes over every once a
while and what ends up happening is
Amanda finds out that date lines coming
out date lines going to do a one-hour
special and now I realize I just can't
stay here anymore you know I like the
United States I didn't really want to
leave the United States because I know I
knew how to basically I knew how to run
a scam in the United States I don't
really know what it's gonna be like in
another country but I know I can't stay
here so we've got a few million we've
got unfortunately have a million or so
at least in real estate so the money's
all over the place but we got some money
so we decide look we're gonna get a
couple of to three million dollars out
and then I'll take off I've got a month
or so I've got the real estate I satisfy
all the loans on everything I have we
start I start borrowing
we start having people cash get cash for
us one of the things was this a girl she
ends up getting it Amanda ends up asking
her to cash them checks I don't know
that that's what sparked the
conversation but somehow or another
Amanda ends up telling her why she's
like you understand he's leaving he's
going to Australia we'd already research
done the research on Australia you can
become a at that time you could become a
permanent resident alien you didn't have
to actually get fingerprints or anything
you could go there you get a driver's
license to get a but you get a lot even
though you can't work there but you can
open a business so you have to like show
up with like two hundred thousand
dollars while showing up with millions
yeah so I'm good
so we decide I'm gonna go Amanda's gonna
come with me and while we're pulling out
the cash it ends up that this girl
contacts the Secret Service and
negotiates a reward for turning me in
and she turns me in and one day I'm
coming back to the apartment
we'd had a robbery like a home invasion
come on mines beforehand so I pull up I
get out of the car about the same time
I'm on the phone with Amanda Amanda
tells me oh my god
I think something went wrong and I'm
like what do you mean she says I just
got a phone call from this other girl
her name was Trina from Trina
and she's asking me where I am she's
asking me a bunch of questions she asked
if I was at the office like didn't want
her to go to the house right and she's I
think she may have done something I'm
like done what she doesn't know anything
and then a man was like I think I [ __ ]
up and so I'm like you what do you mean
I'm getting out of the car and
everything and you know realizing she's
not really telling me but I'm realizing
something's wrong and that's the Secret
Service show up and Wow get on the
ground get on the ground and I just
remember blinking out like I didn't get
on the ground I'm just like just there
you just weren't expecting it then but
you knew that was it you know
the end oh yeah well you know then I lay
down they like he was king on the ground
the guy gets all the way up to me with
the gun he's like and that's the first
so many people yelling I just kind of
like blanked out I remember he goes he
comes right up to me he goes get on the
ground
I was like oh oh so I get on the ground
they cuffed me picks me up they hold up
the poster and they're like that him
he's like it's not him he's like no it's
him it's him it's him so they kind of go
okay it was yeah definitely him is
definitely him so he's like hey mr. Cox
he said we've been looking for you you
are Matt Cox right and I went yeah yeah
unlike Becky who went gangsters all the
way yeah okay so yeah so uh Wow they
drive me back and I eventually I end up
I end up doing Dateline I because when I
got caught the government asked me to be
interviewed by Dateline I was
interviewed by Dateline and you know
they started off saying I stolen 26
million and we argued for a while till I
got him down well and then eventually
the psi which is your pre-sentence
report that they said that there was 9.5
million in loss I ordered about that I
got it down to six million and I ended
up getting sentence and I was sentenced
I thought I was gonna get 12 years and
instead I took a plea for that or I took
a what's called an open plea which means
you get whatever the psi says well my
lawyer looked at the psi and she said
well we can figure it out you did this
this this this this she's like you're in
between 12 to 14 years okay I understand
so we go in thinking 12 to 14 years plus
I'd done the interview for Dateline
which they said they were going to
consider substantial assistance and they
were going to reduce my sentence they
were going to put in something called a
5k 1 to reduce your sentence based on
this interview they asked me to do
technically a 5k one is for cooperation
against your co-defendants but I don't
have any coda thing right yeah Becky's
been caught everybody else in Tampa has
either cooperated and been sentenced or
was not subject to be indicted or they
were going to indict them
but but it'd been so long it hadn't
happened so I just did the interview you
know not that not that I wouldn't have
cooperated and didn't fully intend to
cooperate I'm ready to cut anybody's
head off to get out of this yeah I'm no
I'm no gangster I mean you got these
guys that are like I'm gonna do the time
I did okay will you do that bro but I'm
not interested in having my son call
another guy dad or have my mother visit
me in prison for the next ten years cuz
I want to act like I'm some kind of
tough guy I filled out paperwork yeah
you know that's the extent of my I
filled out some paperwork I borrowed
some money there's no guns I'm not
they're not getting into a shootout but
there's just nobody it's not possible so
I do the interview and they said they'd
reduce my sentence for it while I get in
there I'm thinking 12 years I got a psi
it says 26 and then the night before my
lawyer is like yeah but this doesn't
apply this then apply don't worry we're
gonna talk to them from the judge we're
gonna get that knocked off she seemed
very confident mm-hmm
and plus you're gonna get your sentence
reduced well the night before the US
Attorney says yeah I'm not gonna reduce
a sentence it's not enough so I go into
sentencing and my lawyer argues in front
of the judge and judge just says no I
disagree I disagree with every
enhancement I disagree I think that
applies I disagree I think that applies
I disagree I think that applies so every
time he says I disagree that 12 years
keeps going on Wow 26 he sentence me to
26 I get 26 years and where is this in
Florida and this was in Atlanta all of
my faces were consolidated like in
Atlanta Tennessee Atlanta South Carolina
Tampa were all consolidated there holy
[ __ ] dude 26 years a bad day
and you know what does that day like
after you guys and it's for 26 I mean
talk about like if I really try to talk
your way out of it still somehow or what
after yeah after all it it's you I'm
done yeah well you know you you always
hold out hope you know doesn't like you
know you can't psychologically I
couldn't sit down and say Oh
I'm just gonna do the time yeah ii-i've
got you know I'm look you know it
doesn't sound good
I'm a schemer mm-hmm I'm always looking
for an angle yeah I'm always trying to
figure out how to get around something
through something over something you
know I'm trying to figure out something
so I'm trying to figure out how do I get
out of this yeah but that day when you
get 26 years and you're walking down you
know that hallway I mean well you're
trying to just digest all that it's a
bad yeah I mean talking about just being
just fundamentally just fractured to the
core I mean I tell you right now I've
never you know and based on like might
me talking about it you know you
wouldn't you wouldn't you know it's a
lot of laughing and joking and you know
and I'm very proud of ya and good
stories you know and and it's it's the
narcissist and me yeah that you know
finds it comical and funny and I it's
very surface you know I don't like I
said I don't really think about the fact
that the Browns had to go through hell
trying to fix the house I told myself
they're just gonna fill out some
paperwork to be fine you know I don't
think I don't really focus on those
things i compartmentalize them but you
know that day I mean just just fractured
my psyche to the point where if I even
think about it or focus on it at all I
mean just I'm just like an emotional
mess well and going you know doing all
of those things going to prison and then
I was sent to a medium because I had so
much time
well there's super maxes which is like
where terrorists go nobody goes there
so there's pins and the pin at Coleman
they have to Penitentiary's and then
they have a medium security prison-- and
they have a low security prison and they
have a camp it's a woman's camp though
yeah so I went to the medium because I
had so much time and I mean I was
nonviolent but the medium no no I mean I
mean your crime wasn't right I was gonna
say this is the first day when I show up
yeah what's it like I get there and as
soon as I get there I get my room
like I meet my celly and I would say
sell it
people hear that they think it's but
that's what you're you're the guy Selman
your cell mate yeah your cellie so I
meet my cellie Mexican guy hey man
what's going on oh yeah okay so I meet
him and I'm walking down stairs and I
remember often they start screaming
lockdown lockdown lockdown and my cellie
runs up to me and he says hey he said
cellie Zelda you got to go in the cell
now we got to go in the cell a Mike okay
what's going on and I we walk into the
cell when we go in the cell Mike what
happen whatever he said Oh someone got
stabbed on the yard
I went someone got stabbed in that he
was in the in the recreation yard
somebody got stabbed like oh my god
someone died and he was no no I just got
stabbed up a little bit you can
understand the different the world
you're in you're like you know it's just
a complete contradict I'm like that's
where you are now yeah you don't talk
day one oh this is day one listen I'm a
I'm a sit I sit at it I'm sitting at it
you know you go into the cafeteria and
you sit down and guys like go use your
scooter yeah all right that's if they
talk at all most people just don't even
really talk they're just you got got I
complain I got just about 26 years and
the one guys like yeah I got thirty for
selling you know a little bit of crack
the other two guys are leaving in a pine
box they're like yeah life life so I
can't even [ __ ] about micron about my
time because this guy got thirty for
selling her for bringing a gun to a to a
ten dollar crack deal and gets thirty
years these two guys are never leaving
alive and so how do you even how do you
even complain after that Wow
so yeah it's so yeah using three years
before they say well look at King for so
long made so much money you let you've
traveled the world and and and all of
that you get twenty six years compared
to a guy who just bought some dope well
at the wrong place at the wrong time and
he got more time than you that's crazy
yeah think of yeah well what's not sure
what's crazy is that I remember watching
TV and
we watched we were watching the news one
day and I'm sitting there watching and
this guy had drowned his like 11 year
old niece he was babysitting her and he
drowned her on purpose and he pled
guilty to 13 years and I remember
thinking he got half my sentence for
drug killed somebody oh yeah she was
playing in a pool and she'd splashed him
and he told her stop and he got pissed
and he drowned her and I remember just
thinking wow so you know you can debate
the amount of time you know it's all
relative some people would say it wasn't
enough some people say it was too much
mm-hmm I feel like it was too much but
then nobody's asking my opinion yeah so
yeah it was it's a it was bad day
[Music]
[Laughter]